i really wanted to ask you this um for  the current events for a recent event  i mentioned dallas uh  what lessons do you draw from the dallas  synagogue hostage incident  well the week after that we had active  shooter training in my synagogues and  one of the things i drew was that  security for  synagogues is important and the second  is that  the reality of anti-semitism  which i had thought had waned when i  first began my rabbinate i thought it's  not going to be such a big issue  it is like an evergreen issue and jews  and all people of goodwill have to take  this really seriously because it has  devastating consequences and if the  world doesn't know that then it just  hasn't been paying attention  you